hello citizens of the reject Nation it's
me Tara Erickson alongside what is your
name again Greg oh God what's the last
name though
Albertsons that's all I gotta think of
today we are watching The SpongeBob
Movie have you seen it of course not I
haven't even seen the show me neither
same page
I wonder if it's going to rain too
drastically affect our Beauty experience
we were both just sitting here silently
not laughing I don't get any of this is
this gonna be all inside jokes that we
don't get I think it's going to be a fun
experience they make a movie they gotta
make it somewhat adjustable for those
who haven't seen the show right all
right well we're diving in you guys so
please don't forget to leave a like and
a comment and also ring the bell
Bell when you subscribe because you're
definitely gonna subscribe and don't
forget that if you guys are a patreon on
patreon you get to watch the full length
reaction and watch along with us with me
and gray like we watch the whole thing
you sit there and you're like wow it's
like you're watching at home with us
it's a cool experience so get on top of
that if you're not already a patron
and now I say super sexy something oh
you were so perfect up until so perfect
it was like every time someone's handed
the intro they're always butchering I
was like Tara's doing better than
everyone oh no dude it's rolling just
roll the roll the real rejects intro
Roll It Roll It and Roll the clip
[Music]
what are you confused by the seagulls
Craig what was it what no I thought it
was like a animated movie
gotta love me some Pirates
[Applause]
gold I never thought I'd see it in the
own eyes
[Music]
oh I was actually really invested in
that intro it's probably really
effective in a movie theater
and it sounds different in the show
[Music]
yeah
go to the theaters you freaks
[Applause]
I think no one sat on those front two
roads yeah those are the worst roads to
sit in back row is where it's at aisle
seat A Story begins in bikini bottoms
popular undersea Eatery the Crusty Krab
restaurant Krusty Krab
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
oh geez
get a hold of yourself Eugene I'm going
in I'm the manager of this establishment
everything's gonna be just mine I'm
really scared here man you got a name
still you got a family Phil I want you
to do me a favor Phil say cheese
[Music]
oh my God that's so dumb I love it
order up
[Applause]
[Music]
it
was all a dream today is the grand
opening ceremony for the Krusty Krab 2
where Mr Krabs will announce the new
manager this is not gonna go the way you
want well let's ask my wall of 374
consecutive employee of the month of War
nice
oh big bathroom I want that bathroom oh
okay
all right
it's actually pretty inventive yeah I
support that
no that's awesome
oh
it's scary
oh my gosh this reminds you like Mr Bean
that's me in the shower
[Music]
that's Greg and John in the shower I
could say I'll be thanking you in my
managerial acceptance speech today
tonight after my big promotion we're
gonna party party to purple
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is so hyper
goofy goober yeah
please tell me there's Goofy Goober ice
cream somewhere
crab restaurant for years the only place
to get a delicious and mouth-watering
crabby patty that is a great animated
looking Burger long time owner Mr Krabs
opening a new restaurant called the
Krusty Krab 2. exactly oh my God right
next door hello
crab right next door to the original
Money capitalism crabs is being
interviewed by perch Perkins and I've
never even had one
[Music]
well it might just be the marketing
buddy I just mopped the floors who
carried my computer wife
the secret to crab success the formula
for the Krabby Patties that people would
line up to eat at my restaurant there
are some high stakes here I've exhausted
every evil plan in my filing cabinet
from a to y the letter after why
[Music]
that was clever
and I will rule the world oh hell plated
[Laughter]
oh I think I stepped in something
no now before we begin with the ribbon
cutting I'd like to announce the name of
our new manager
who's it gonna be is it gonna be the
squid
[Applause]
[Music]
I knew it
that's like that Oscar upset with La La
Land This is like Zoolander you didn't
get the job what why you want to
employee of the month like all the time
365 days a million million times he's
more uh
I'm not mature I mean this in the nicest
of ways character are coming in but
there's a word for what you are and that
word is uh Ding-A-Ling nuts
expensive
big spasitron and to be a manager you
have to be a man you understand I guess
so Mr Krabs
just open up your own Burger Joint but
is he mature enough to do that
there's adult humor in this
poor squid didn't get a party
I get the world yeah I get the world I
don't need to watch a whole show
multiple Seasons
you have confessed to the crime of
touching the king's crowd but it's my
job your highness I'm the Royal Crown
polisher
oh my goodness
and the dungeon it is you're free to go
bless you princess Mindy what a good
princess I wish you'd try a little love
and compassion instead of these harsh
punishments that would be nice
the Draconian way of rule is not the way
to go this Crown entitles the one who
wears it to be in charge of the sea
wear it until you learn how to rule with
an iron fist like your father
[Music]
your crown
what the
[Music]
oh that's no good you cannot rule a sea
without a crown but the crown is useless
without a king I don't know I feel like
the crown does it all
hey goobers I want to go to here this
place looks amazing oh I'm a goofy
goober yeah
oh my God that's a survey
[Applause]
the nut bar get it together oh boy I
know I'll just stop thinking about it
that's called denial I usually feel a
little better I don't even remember why
I was sad hey it's the new Krusty Krab 2
manager you didn't get them no he just
set the place on fire and ran away
asking if they saw his butt
me with most desserts I'm feeling better
this is too much
I was not prepared for how kinetic this
would be get up yeah
hey come on buddy I want to go home come
on pal oh my goodness oh whoa does he
also have pink eye he looks like so
hungover good morning go scrape up your
friend and get going
um
work that doesn't respect you
aim crabs your heinous
are you left one damning piece of
evidence at the scene I stole your crown
[Music]
oh man
that was the master plan before I turn
this conniving crustacean into fish meal
who here has anything to say about
Eugene Krabs I got something oh no I
love this oh my God yes please
Kingdom
I
now realize that he's a great big jerk I
deserve that manager's job
anyone else no well then
you gotta have an alibi man how could
you not have an alibi
[Applause]
[Music]
hey you sobered up very quickly Mike
Crown is a symbol of my king-like
authority and uh between you and me my
hair is thinning a bit so I'm sure it's
not that noticeable
oh my God
he's so wild if I went to get your crown
back no one who's gone to Shell city has
ever returned you're just a kid he's a
sponge he's willing to risk his life to
find your crown and save his boss but
daughter I please father oh my God
that's Scarlett Johansson's voice it
doesn't take that long to figure it out
be back here with my crown in exactly 10
days you can do it in nine eight seven
six what are you doing until then the
crabtale remain Frozen where he now
wait
ing oh turn on the AC Mr Krabs you
didn't hear any of this there's a giant
Cyclops who guards the outskirts of the
city and preys on innocent sea creatures
don't let him catch you because if he
does he'll take you back oh my gosh he's
so excited take this what's in here
the magical bag of winds
open the bag of wins and you'll be blown
back home I'm coming there's such a
frenetic energy about this you've got
nothing to worry about your life is in
our hands
[Music]
hardcore relied on this is a visual
comedy it is it's really really
impressive
good like the coffee is so much of the
editing too oh yeah it's great they do a
really good job of pacing in this movie
oh no that's amazing on a Paddy Wagon
steel belted pickles
rejected french fryer with dual overhead
grease traps oh my God if you could get
an airplane this should be a real real
Park that'd be great what
I like to run around but I've got crabby
patties to make over at the chub bucket
oh I will say that the Chum Bucket is
very dirty and I wouldn't eat a sandwich
there he's such a diabolical genius why
is he trying to run a restaurant yeah he
should be like stealing creatures under
the sea and like stashing them in the
Chum Bucket do I need to watch a whole
show to understand we're off to get King
Neptune's Crown in Shell City Lord take
off your hat and respect respect for the
day
dance
over the county line oh yeah we'll see
about that
out of the car fellas uh oh
oh no man barely had it such a cool
Paddy Wagon
oh wow
he cleaned it up at least
[Music]
die out music is a nice touch
indicate that they're going after the
crown I've already hired someone to take
care of those two
dead Dennis
I'll kill you I'll kill you fool
[Music]
evidence
that's violent do they never talk again
oh that's no good
oh my goodness
we must be close by now this is like
Reese Witherspoon in that one movie
where she has to hike a lot
okay SpongeBob look our car
[Music]
these cutaways man they're really good
at that
oh there it is the key
how are we gonna get it I get HP
Lovecraft beat him in pool
everybody's attention
I have to use the bathroom right over
there
stupid contacts oh my goodness it's a
face
[Music]
you should be getting keys and driving
but you know what I support this bubble
party it looks like a lot of fun they're
trying to say they're just kids but I'm
pretty sure they suffer with the
Attention Deficit Hyperactive Disorder
right yes
[Music]
oh my God no time for the test no baby
can resist singing along to this Patrick
uh don't do it don't sing to it
I'll turn it up louder
[Music]
oh that's so great I'm a goofy goober
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
what
oh saved by the Siamese twins looks like
we got a
you can't survive that
what is the commentary on beating up
Siamese people that they're doing here
at least they got the key well I got it
at the Chum Bucket Plankton's giving
them away free with every Krabby Patty
is there some type of mind control thing
you may have put Wings everyone else in
this fat Watertown but you can't fool me
I listen to Public Radio
he's an NPR guy you set up Mr Krabs you
stole the crown so Neptune would freeze
him and you could finally get your
stubby little paws on the Krabby Patty
formula ah he gotcha
but you made one fatal mistake you
messed with my paycheck
now activating helmet brain controlled
oh you called it yes
okay
all right Chum Bucket you have to really
rely on everyone really obsessively
wearing these yeah yeah like do they not
take them off what okay
whoa
how do they see
there's no way out
the world's getting kind of bumpy here
hey look free ice cream
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a setup it's a trap wait a minute
[Laughter]
okay Patrick
I said Let go please oh
are you
are they in a mouth
[Applause]
holy junk
[Music]
can't be that sharp
well he just blew a bubble so
much
WoW one punch
that's pretty far oh right in the tug
boat
no more boat okay
[Music]
wow Circle of Life horrors of the
trenches
where's the road
this is where we find out if they can
swim
oh boy hey SpongeBob look here's the way
down oh well we're not gonna get the
ground standing here on to Shell City
the stairs talk I'm going home Patrick
but what about Mr Krabs we'll never
survive in that trench this is man's
country but you're gonna die either way
show us your man and go down in that
scary trench pull your pants up Patrick
we're going home but you can't go home I
knew it oh Mindy is her name I heard
enough did you see my underwear no
Patrick did you want to ah Patrick no
or should I say blank topless what is
this a magic mirror this Monument is
celebrating my glory is it gonna build
itself move faster
Anarchy Squidward
oh no even Gary
oh but we're just hey it doesn't matter
if you're kids and what's so wrong with
being a kid anyway Kids Rule yeah I mean
kind of I mean keeping their child likes
in you is the thing that Sparks
imagination and creativity
why I guess I'll just have to turn you
into men good old reverse psychology
with my Mermaid Magic
but because they're so childlike they'll
be able to convince themselves
yeah they're susceptible to it I'm with
you on that they're very malleable
oh my God
so now that you're men can you make it
to Shell City
oh
I don't think it's working as well as
she thought it would
[Applause]
[Music]
why did we jump over the edge instead of
taking the stairs
because we're Invincible ah
oh it's good nice
men land we're safe and sound at the
bottom of this trench
oh consistent visual gags man Now That
We're Men we can do anything
[Music]
you know what this feels psychedelic
yeah I was like do people get high and
then watch SpongeBob yeah it feels very
trippy
[Music]
oh my gosh they have an army now
[Applause]
you lost your army because you were a
meanie are they sure the crowns in Shell
City could have just been a mislead I've
been ironed
my friend here in a good mood today so
I'm gonna let you off with a warning
awesome Wrath of our mustaches
[Music]
oh no this tennis is a Dream Crusher man
Plankton was very specific
wanna meet a stick
find out that he stole the crown wow
this guy's revealing everything perhaps
I've said too much you sure have Dennis
these are sharp kind of cool boots I'd
be into wearing those
oh
[Music]
that's cool awesome that's really clever
that's Cyclops to come around like that
what where does he take these why does
he want them yeah that's what I'm saying
is he gonna do like a science experiment
he's he's a marine biologist he's not
hooked up to anything how does he get
back to the surface great question
artificially colored rocks
[Applause]
oh no they're in a tank
yeah I'll go like we see buddy
[Music]
yep yep those fish are dead dead
man aren't you on isn't it kind of hard
to breathe in that helmet
uh
[Music]
it's good okay he's full-on sociopath
you think so oh
no oh no
their perspective
on this lamp tell me about it there's
like some weird body horror stuff in
this I don't even think we're gonna be
able to save ourselves buddy
oh this is disturbing at least they die
together
we never made it to Shell City Shell
City
[Music]
and so
Shell city is a gift shop but if this is
Shell City then where's the crown
[Music]
this is horrifying
oh boy oh the tears can loosen them up
oh
[Music]
oh my gosh the music I can't imagine
watching this in the theater
I'm being a child dude like what is
happening
oh
no trippy
wow that tear can really move
okay the chairs do something but I
didn't think he was gonna do this oh
it's like a defibrillator shock em back
to life nope okay but they're dried out
uh sprinklers okay all right
get back up to SpongeBob and Patrick
come on
yay ready one
how are they gonna oh
foreign
[Music]
oh yeah now they're all coming back to
life because of the agua is that what's
happening you're in trouble now Cyclops
I don't think that's what's happening no
okay someone just oh my charger right
yeah
taste your own medicine man Point bag
away from home okay plant feet firmly on
ground
step three remove string from bag
releasing the wins sure
what have you done now you're really
gonna be have to come a man and find
your way back home with the crown you
gotta put in the work the Bikini Bottom
now I can take you there no way oh man
oh my God it's actually David
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
guess who's here
[Music]
hopeful I'm like what dolphin now it's
like a boat oh
oh interesting what if we run now we'll
never stop yeah Patrick oh man
[Music]
I was happening on David Hassell
Park nice now
[Music]
no gosh
survive not in his foot oh
oh nice but we'll never be able to float
down in time
oh my goodness
the control
wow David Hasselhoff
looking pretty good for his age
done
no no not David
a beautiful town I knew you could do it
My Parade shall be quite dry under my
umbrella
oh no oh my no
[Music]
um
I'm Evil Genius and you're just a kid
you're so mean it's really not nice
under the sea I made it to shelter
oh my gosh can singing get them out of
mind control
what
[Music]
oh my God people definitely do drugs and
see this one this is the most unexpected
thing in the world
oh boy
[Music]
ah yes
nice that's pretty cool
hell yeah whoa cool
[Music]
this is insane it's the wizard who saved
us out of my way fool stomp on him
yay Karma man may I say so you are a
very lucky fellow to have in your
employees such a brave faithful and
heroic young lad he's a great man
hmm
oh my goodness I'm on it
I'm sorry I ever doubted you that's a
mistake I won't make again make a
manager I think we all know who
rightfully deserves to wear that manager
pin I couldn't agree more sir oh my God
Squidward's coming around for him too
it is the greatest day of my life
[Music]
wow all right Journey okay
is that what the series is like because
does it go into like
where you're like on a trip like a like
a trip
so
you follow John mulaney's career at all
uh kind of
well John Mulaney
was on drugs and then he got sober and
his latest standard special deals a lot
with him being sober for the past year
or whatever okay
this kind of Comedy
feels like what it's like when John
Mulaney is probably on drugs
there's a lot of the sensibilities the
the dialogue the humor
seem like a guy who's on a very specific
kind of drug
s
or acid right yeah or a little bit of
sniffy sniffy stuff yep so trying to
watch some stuff for kids
but we've said enough but yeah that is
uh I was not prepared me neither I did
not realize that it really would turn
into certain parts where you if you've
been to Disneyland the end of the rides
are just like this the dark moments in
this movie here what is happening here
oh is this like some post oh no
I
literally just finished watching The
Little Mermaid live action movie and now
talked about it extensively then five
minutes later
showed up while I was filming that I did
sort of five minutes unlocked the door
for me from his phone and then and then
we're like all right Tara let's watch
SpongeBob which is another Under the Sea
experience it was Scarlett Johansson
that was Baldwin is Dennis okay knew it
and then I experienced this which was a
drastically different Under the Sea
experience and I had to learn I did not
know this is how SpongeBob SquarePants
Works me neither
I mean it was it was fun but I was also
I feel like not prepared I feel like I
needed to be on a little something right
like there are some really funny moments
though there no no it's hilarious but
I'm saying like when it cuts into
certain songs in certain parts I feel
like people are laughing the entire time
if you have a little help well the
comedy is non-stop that's what I mean
like 20 it never breeds fruits yeah do
you feel like that sometimes with that
like you get a little worn it's a little
over it's it's a little overwhelming
like I can't laugh that much yeah yeah
right it's a little overwhelming and
then you become a little like
um desensitized to it because it just
it keeps going it keeps going it keeps
going and then I don't often say this
word for anything it truly is random
there is no Rhyme or Reason to it nope
and the show if I'm not mistaken is 22
minutes an episode okay this is under a
little under 80. yeah it's a very
different experience than a 22 minute
chakra right for sure yeah I mean there
were some Hilarious Moments pretty much
from beginning to end there was
something and it was doing wrong it's
very creative it feels like a writer's
room full of people who like take a
little something something and then they
just spit out random ideas and piece it
together you know I was thinking that
when I was watching I was like this
script well how did it get approved it's
not like
I mean it is the way that they put it
all together with these characters it
works but like on the page I was
thinking like was nobody like we should
make this more like add in more stuff or
do more bait and switches but I'm like
oh with the character set it like it
works perfectly even though I haven't
seen I want to see what the Rotten
Tomatoes score is oh man I would love to
know
okay
68 approved okay and the audience scores
78 percent
it's a really goofy and entertaining for
both children and their parents yeah
okay surreal is a good one for it
surreal yeah this is surreal it was
trippy it was psychedelic yeah it was
um kinetic uh and there's I there there
is also there is a story at the end I
can't say there's no story I don't yeah
um believe in yourself but it doesn't
it's been a while since I've seen a
movie where they they don't even attempt
to take anything seriously it's kind of
crazy like they don't take anything
seriously
yeah I guess you're right about that
even even uh Mindy Mindy was kind of the
only one who was like even though it
sounded sometimes sarcastic when she
would talk was the the only one who was
slightly serious about like Dad stop all
this killing and listen to me she was
the only sound one that was like I'll
help you do this
um uh otherwise everyone else was just
like on a limb well yeah I mean uh even
in her scenes though it was there was
constantly like just I'm saying there's
not once one scene in here right is
there's something even if it's like
they're dying on the lamp thing like
there's some comedy happening at all
times at all times uh yeah it's a bit
overwhelming
and I feel like I feel like SpongeBob's
eyes right now where I'm like whoa I was
not prepared for this yeah for this trip
that we went on me neither but it was
there but it was constantly have
something though where every once in a
while I would be like that is freaking
hysterical
I I agree with that I just couldn't
laugh the entire time I don't know that
I necessarily wanted to because it was
all I was always funny but like I was
always like oh this is fun I was always
amused it was I mean admittedly there
would be times where I was a little
annoyed yeah only because like I don't
know SpongeBob
and uh my brain was not ready for this
right and so once in a while I would be
annoyed but then I would suddenly be
like oh now I'm laughing yeah he has to
grow on you I feel like these the both
of the characters and the uh when it
really grew on me when I really was like
oh okay I understand it when he was
drunk when he and he shows up drunk he's
like I'll tell you what's wrong then I
was like okay I get that that's very
very funny and now I understand the
character is a little bit better in that
moment for me I was surprised by how
sometimes there would be like some like
true adult humor not just like oh these
are jokes adults would get like no this
is straight up like a lot of just like
crap humor yeah a little bit vulgar yeah
um you know like the the hymn like hung
over jokes or yeah
that was
that was great yeah they had that moment
it it would it would fluctuate between
um between these moments and so yeah I
think it's not just adjusting the
character but adjusting to the style
because the characters all
representative of the style
yeah I like I like the Squidward
character I was like oh I feel like he
he would have helped balance out some of
this energy because he's like the one
who lives in the most reality yeah if he
would have been in it more right like
been in Incorporated in it
um if he was on the journey with them
yeah or if he was like this manager job
is to is like too overwhelming for him
so he decides to go try and find them on
the like the oh after
what
folks have to leave
okay
okay all righty okay I thought something
was gonna happen there at the end
you just slowly slowly exit
um oh and I also really like the I I
love I think there's a lot of great
things about the editing and the the way
that it's like smash the things that
have just this great visual comedy
elements throughout like the visual
comedy can be really strong in here for
an anime if for animation instead of
like sometimes you watch these animated
movies that are gonna be annoying for
people where the comedy is really
reliant on like stupid pop culture jokes
or whatever yeah this is physical it's
all physical yeah there's there's almost
something Leslie Nielsen about it Leslie
Nielsen me like Naked Gun meets like a
Family Guy
meets like a Cartoon Network show yeah
yeah there's a lot of different uh
elements to it but it's like the smash
cuts to their reactions were really
funny it was mostly them being like
silent yeah and wide-eyed and they're
like uh and that that was like the one
relief that I was like that's very very
that's funny and it's also giving us one
second where they're not constantly
talking or trying to like make us laugh
I guess with the dialogue yeah which was
cool
yeah but uh SpongeBob grew on me over
time even Patrick who I thought was
really frustrating at first eventually
became like he had some really funny
moments yeah uh overall yeah I mean are
we dead I liked when every time he like
he always had three words like are we
there like are we dead which I really
enjoy I would like to watch the first
episode of the show yeah all right okay
yeah yeah yeah like I bet you if you
watch the whole series these two guys
really grow on you because you have only
22 minutes you don't have to like not
have to but you're not sitting through
80 minutes of like an adventure with
them I think in short bursts these two
will really really grow on you well if
you already seen the show it says five
stars at a 7.2 so clearly the fans of
the show like that they love it yeah
because if this um it was like I liked
it I can't say I loved it even though
there were some jokes that I absolutely
loved
um because yeah people who wanted to
watch the show they already know they're
already emotionally they already are
like the characters they already love
everyone yeah exactly and then they're
watching this then they're watching the
movie whereas I'm like cold man this is
an introduction like I've seen stuff of
Squidward in the past of like little
things people have posted and like I
can't really tell you anything about
SpongeBob I've seen like things about
nothing that was like character defining
traits of him and and I was aware I've
heard of Krusty Krav I didn't know that
it was a place that SpongeBob worked at
and I've heard the song
um so that was my familiarity is very
limited any of those things yeah go
about it okay yeah for this was uh it
was like okay now I understand some of
these references I've heard and then you
didn't know anything no so as newbies
yeah this was our honest take on it
throughout honest hot take but
um
huh any last words I'm brain fried right
now this is really it's really I want to
talk so my brain is fried I feel like I
went through shocking water I was like I
need to keep my eyes open and be
registering everything they're saying my
eyes are really wide open right now
there's some really great visuals too
there's great visual Panache and I like
like Hasselhoff showing up I thought
like that oh that was great the
commitment of it and the creepiness and
there was like body horror elements to
talk to the PEC smash
that was great there's something about
the SpongeBob world that reminds me of
like I'm a big fan I'm a fan of HP
Lovecraft who a lot of his world is like
humanoid fish people and a lot of that
reminded me of this but like a parody
spoof version of it so that was fun
that was fun yeah
the review has been us trying to
understand what SpongeBob SquarePants
have been like what I feel like we just
got here
we're like you guys what happened
the hair is like it's blasted back our
eyes are wide open and red and we're
just shaking like we just watched the
SpongeBob movie and we knew nothing
about it going in that's us that was
wild yeah you guys will leave a comment
let us know what what you think what you
thought if you've watched all the
episodes why we are terrible people for
not and
um because we would love to hear all
about it
um and what do I say for the patrons uh
if you could just send it I need a
shower or something now
yeah not not together and we'll see you
guys later that's it from us bye
[Music]
okay